- So in the last video, we
did our circuit analysis.
We set up the four
equations that we needed
to solve in order to
figure out all the voltages
and currents in our example circuit.
And so now, we're gonna solve it.
This is a matter of doing the algebra
to solve a set of four
simultaneous equations.
What I wanna do now is just
write my equations down here
and tidy them up a little bit.
So the first one we're gonna bring down
is the voltage statement here,
which I can write as
V1 plus V2
equals Vs.
I'm gonna bring down the
i equation over here.
It's gonna be
i1 minus i2
equals Is.
And now I have to pick.
I have four variables here.
I'm gonna start doing substitutions
based on these expressions up here.
These are my Ohm's law expressions.
So we're gonna use those to
substitute for the voltages,
and we're gonna solve the whole
thing in terms of currents.
So the first equation becomes V1 is
R1 i1 plus
R2 i2
equals Vs.
Second equation stays the same.
i1 minus i2
equals Is.
The next step in the solution is gonna be
to figure out how to eliminate
one of these currents.
Now I think what I'll do is I'll eliminate
i2, and I can do that if
I multiply this equation
by R2 and add these equations together.
So let's do the
multiplication by R2 first.
We'll rewrite the first equation up here.
R1 i1 plus R2 i2
equals Vs, and then
down, the bottom equation
is gonna be R2 i1
minus R2 i2
equals R2 Is.
We're gonna add these equations together.
And we can see these
terms nicely cancel out,
and so I'm gonna end up with
R1 plus R2
times i1 equals
Vs plus R2
Is.
And I can get the solution
in symbolic terms for i1.
I1 equals
Vs plus R2 Is
over R1 plus R2.
What I wanna do now is actually put in
the original real values
and solve this circuit
all the way through.
So we'll move up and keep going.
So let me sketch the circuit again,
the real circuit again.
We had a voltage source
with fifteen volts.
It went to a 4k resistor, that was R1.
We had a 2k resistor here
and a current source,
and that was 3 milliamps.
And we want to discover...
This was i1, and this was i2.
Those are the two unknown currents.
Let's see if we can find those.
So i1
equals Vs, 15
plus R2 is 2k times Is, three milliamps
divided by 4k plus 2k.
So let's solve this.
That equals 15
plus 2k times three
milliamps is six volts.
This is volts, and that's divided by
6k equals 21 volts over 6k
equals 3.5 milliamps.
So that's this value right here,
3.5 milliamps
is i1.
So we have one of our unknown currents,
and we wanna find the other one.
That's sitting right here.
We can figure out i2.
Minus i2 equals Is minus i1
equals three milliamps minus
3.5 milliamps
equals minus .5.
Let's get rid of the minus signs.
i2 equals 0.5 milliamps.
That's that value right there.
Let's put some boxes around
our answers we have so far.
Here's one.
And here's another one, there's i2 and i1.
And now let's finish up by
figuring out the voltages.
We can use Ohm's law to
figure out the voltage
across the 4k resistor, and that's V1.
So V1 equals i, which is 3.5
milliamps times 4k.
4k ohms and that equals,
three and a half times four
is 14 volts.
Whenever you multiply
milliamps times k ohms,
those units cancel, and you get volts.
So V1 equals 14 volts.
And our last current,
sorry, our last voltage
is V2, is the voltage right here.
And V2
equals i2 which we decided was .5 milliamp
times two thousand ohms, 2k.
And V2 equals one volt.
And now we've solved our circuit.
That's a complete circuit analysis
using the fundamental laws.